The exotic pet trade makes for great
Instagramming. But people with weird pets
are seriously messing up the environment
and costing us millions of dollars in
the process.
Hello, everyone, I'm Trace (as you may know)
and today we have a special guest from
Shed Science, Sally Le Page. Hi, Sally. Hello, thanks for having me.
Welcome. Every year pet owners are
faced with the dilemma of what to do
with unwanted companions. In Boulder,
Colorado, a handful of goldfish were
released into a local lake and now there
are thousands of them.
Goldfish are actually carp, like the
well-known coy carp. They're native to
Japan
so they've got no natural predators here
in the US. They could be carrying viruses
and if they escape lakes and head
downstream they could out-compete native
fish, some of which are already
threatened. You may think of him as cute
little Mr Bubbles.
What harm could he possibly do? But removing
these species costs the government a lot
of money and time, and it's not just our
goldfish. In 1890, a fan of William
Shakespeare named Eugene Shefflin wanted
to bring the birds from Shakespeare's
works into his home of New York. He
released a hundred starlings that are
native to Europe, Asia, Africa, and
Australia into Central Park. And by 1928,
those 100 beds had bred so much that
the population reached the Mississippi
River. By 1942, they had spread all the
way to California, forming flocks of as
many as a million hungry birds driving
off native species like bluebirds and
woodpeckers. And today there are an
estimated 200 million starlings flying
around North America, costing eight
hundred million dollars in damage to
agriculture every year and unknown
millions in damage to the airline
industry through bird strikes. They even
caused a plane crash in 1960.
It's not just the waterways and skies
harboring introduced species.
Oh, no, no, no. There are two states which
bear the brunt of these animals:
Florida and Hawaii. In a 20-year Florida
study, they found 56 different non-native
species completely established in
America's favorite little dangly state.
Pythons are a well-known invader
but what about the newest reptilian
invader: the Argentine tegu? This
black-and-white lizard is just starting
to breed and spread into parts of the
state.
How did it get there? Exotic pet release.
Their study found eighty-four percent of
all introduced species in Florida came
from exotic pets.
Tegus grow up to four feet in length and
lay 35 eggs a year. Once established, they'll
compete with feral cats and dogs, as well
as native animals like raccoons.
Florida is also home to wild hogs. Not
that better-than-expected John Travolta
movie. No. Literally, wild pigs. Yeah.
The hogs were introduced in the 1500's by
the Spanish. But Europeans have their
invaders, too, like the red-eared slider or
Terrapin.
It's from the Mississippi Valley but
it's been found as far away as Europe and
Asia. The red-eared slider females are
larger than most native turtles, so they can
out-eat, out-mate, and out-breed. And
apparently most male native turtles like
the larger ladies. And indeed
who wouldn't? You see, bigger females make
more eggs, so of course they're more
attractive to the males. As years go by,
more and more non-native species get
spread around, even trees. The Norway
maple, a beautiful tree, grows so fast and
has such dense shade it displaces native
trees, shrubs, and herbs, as well as
flowers, which affects the native forest
life. And trees are essential for some
species of forest life, and the Norway
maple out-competes native maples for
resources, causing the native tree
populations to die and affecting the
animals that live in and around them.
Just don't plant them. But if you aren't
into cutting down beautiful maple trees,
even if they are invasive, you could help
by getting an environmentally friendly
car.
The new Toyota Mirai is looking to the
future with sustainability in mind,
fueled by hydrogen and leaving
zero-emissions behind. Now that California
and other southwestern regions are
beginning to react to this massive
drought, chances are we'll see more
native plants and landscaping that
require less water and are more suited
to our habitat. That's probably good.
There are solutions to the drought, but
desalination isn't going to do it.
For more on that, check out Julian's
video here. "It can only make ten percent
of the county's needs and it'll use a
lot of energy because it's forcing
pressurized water through a membrane to
separate the water from the salt in a
process called reverse osmosis." And thank
you for watching.
Also, you can come find Sally ... where can they come find you? They can come find me on youtube.com
forward slash shedscience
Thanks for coming. Thanks! Bye.